hello and welcome to this video playing
crocodile small yeah funny one yeah
thank you don't beat me and I call the
big crocodile crocodile big okay so
let's see in d5 or not that's the
question here
most people know I shouldn't cannot play
to pre moves at once
most people playing the hedgehog go for
this yeah it is on the board a lot this
is an opening line that is not very
fashionable nowadays but nothing wrong
with it in particular so what is going
on here
yeah it seems like he wants to play
Knight to c6 but well seem more rooks is
7 and then d5 you know okay let's
provoke 97 maybe he goes with this 2d 7
with the f6 one no
95 and then night if for is an idea
actually a little bit awkward
it's a bit a bit awkward hmm
what did I do wrong there
I don't know I've had two I've played
this I have played this like a million
times so I should know how it works but
somehow I applied it badly 97 years old
why not 94 I thought that was kind of
kind of mandatory okay what does he do
now it's going to be tricky now to
defend the center b-66 is hanging now
everything works fine for me
I thought 94 wasn't that possible hmm
very strange
okay so Knight takes e5 him now I can
take b5 night b6 then take on d6 should
work
hmm does he have a decision here I can
actually just take on these six because
of the because of the mate threat and
this is probably the best way to do it
after Bishop takes rook takes on
threatening mate with rookie aid and if
it takes a four I can take a five so
threatening maid now
okay so Knight b6 I guess
came ninety seven traits traits the
house don't know if that is the best
solution however F for though what about
F for therefore ninety seven minutes to
it
ninety-seven is the thing okay
the main reason for this move is that I
have 25 seconds I just want to be able
to play some quick moves
wonder what he was thinking there my
idea is simply to go to the b-pawn
it's not super easy to do
yeah we'll see we'll see what what is
that doing no I'm just going there right
just going to before now I cannot go to
see five before check
and it's that's just winning now I think
getting a ruku t6 chicken then I'm not
just talk winning winning ecigs
but I'm willing to be five if he moves
to walk away okay so just get the pawns
rolling out don't care about the Jeep on
yeah don't I can't keep this opponent
doesn't hurt
I'm just a seven or you can also check
use the king now a seven rook c8 mate
it's a bit of a problem
yeah kinda he simply cannot defend
against it okay one I can still play a
seven yeah there was an odd game in the
opening I think I made some very good
decisions there and got into trouble so
this position I had on the board a
million times really and what did I do
them so I don't believe this can be too
bad but probably what I'm doing now is
not good yeah this rook t2 this doubling
on the D file is probably not a good
idea
what white wants to do ideally is to
push this King it to air form that would
be the best possible scenario on g4 is
one of the moves that the engine is
giving yeah this is probably not great I
mean it gets really hot here now Knight
c3 has the engine and this is now
probably just a mistake
35 and now 94 I thought he has to go 94
and then I have to do really awkward
things yeah who if I wanted to play
rookie to the engine gives the brutal
move G Phi a B five now I didn't see b5
I was to thinking that my position makes
a strange impression because yeah this
is always in the air and yeah doesn't
look good
this is very brutal so the engine wants
to play like this that would have been
tough to play really Knight a to c3 only
moves basically
Wow Wow
it's not fun I mean black has a huge
initiative yeah I wouldn't have survived
that one I don't think so
instead he went back and now after night
a three I'm in great shape
really now everything works out works
out fine so take steaks i took on d5 the
engine wants to immediately caption on
d6 said a mistake not not a huge one so
like b6y and now the question is if 97
is good f4 seems to be really bad 94 is
strong wow I didn't see that at all
he's got this so I was just thinking if
he moves the night I check on d7 yeah
okay but this is of course just nothing
so f1 was a bad idea I should I should
do this then and claim that this ending
is the one to go for I was thinking I
this good man could be it wrong
this this this
you know black handsome join Shawn to
see for sure
okay so f4 and 94 after he missed that
it should be a slightly better version
of the mention ending but it was still
not so easy to make any headway until he
played rook a 5 which is really strange
move it's kind of clear that I want to
go to before and now he's allowing me
exactly that no now with with the c5 and
so on it's it's an easy win you just
pick up the pawns and invade ok guys
thanks for watching